[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin PT
science chemistry PhD and owner of pink
hair
I had purple and mohair for about six
months but the purple I had really sunk
and it's way in and I couldn't get it to
the warm peachy color that I really
wanted but I was a bit scared of just
bleaching it because I had to bleach it
twice the first time to get it to get to
purple and so it was already pretty
damaged so here's how I did it if you
like this sort of video give it a thumbs
up make sure you subscribe to my channel
and click the notification bell so you
don't miss any videos the dice that I've
been using are called direct J's these
dyes have big pigment molecules that
stick to the outside of the hair shaft
and usually if they'll wash away
eventually
but sometimes the molecules absorb a bit
too deep into the hair for it to wash
out which is what happened to me the
standard way of fading stayed hair is by
using bleach bleach breaks up the dye
molecules which stops them from
absorbing colored light which stops them
from looking colored so for example what
I think was stating my hair was the dye
basic violet - which absorbs light in
the yellow and green regions so when
white light hits it the yellow and the
green get absorbed and the rest of the
color mostly red and purple it bounces
off and that's what hits your eye and so
that's what it looks like but when
bleach comes in and breaks up the dye
molecule it stops absorbing light in the
visible color range the problem is that
bleach damages your hair in a bunch of
different ways bleach is an oxidizing
agent and this causes a bunch of
different types of damage called
oxidative damage firstly it breaks up
disulfide bridges in your hair and this
makes it a lot weaker and it breaks a
lot more easily especially in water it
swells up and it goes really floppy
bleach also removes some of the fatty
acids that are normally bound to the
outside of your hair and what this means
is that your hair is less soft less
silky it also tangles more easily and it
doesn't hold on to hair conditioner as
well it also makes your hair more
hydrophilic or water-loving
and this means that it swells more when
it's wet and because much weaker
it also breaks up proteins in your hair
which makes the hair cuticle chip away
and this makes your hair dull and rough
but one of the biggest problems is
despite all this damage it still might
not completely work so it might not
break the dye molecules enough it still
absorbs light but now the light is
different and so you end up with weird
colors coming through the method I'm
using I found on the hair crazy website
it's called Katie's direct dye fading
treatment and I've linked it in the
description box before using the
treatment you should try to clarify your
hair and repair it as much as possible
so used a clarifying shampoo I used
olaplex to try to repair the bonds and I
avoided silicones in my hair products
for a few days right now my hair is like
this pale purplish color but the purple
just won't leave so what I'm gonna try
to do today is fade it down to a paler
shade that I can turn peach later on the
first step is to apply coconut oil to
dry hair and then wait for two hours if
anyone knows the methods they're getting
liquid coconut oil onto your hair
without it going everywhere I would love
it because it is literally dripping
everywhere right now and it's going to
be a pain to clean
coconut oil has saturated fatty acids
which means that its structure is skinny
enough to absorb between the cuticle
scales of your hair and this dissolves
up some of the dye molecules and gets
them out without any harshness I'm only
doing the treatment on half my hair so
we have a comparison to see how well it
fades alright so that's pretty saturated
now I'm just going to leave it for two
hours
you make a mix of 15% ammonia free
bleach powder 80% clarifying shampoo and
5% oils then you apply it over the oily
hair so you don't rinse the oil out and
work it through the hair like you're
scrubbing her I think this is the better
way you do end up damaging your hair a
bit because you are physically scrubbing
at your hair the surfactants in the
shampoo help lift the cuticle scales and
the bleach powder which is our claim
with a high pH does as well so now even
though you're using all this bleach
powder it actually ends up at a lower
concentration than you think the shampoo
doesn't really contain enough water to
make it dissolve completely and it
doesn't work as a proper bleach unless
the pacific salt in it is dissolved so
some of it will act like bleach but most
of the bleach powder will actually act
like a physical exfoliant working the
dye out of the hair after scrubbing for
about five minutes you cap and warm it
with a hairdryer for five to ten minutes
I only did half my hair so I use cling
wrap
the heat decreases the surface tension
of all the liquid so it soaks into the
hair diva plus it lists the cuticle a
little bit again for deeper removal
finally you shampoo everything out in
hot water
so I've let my hair air dry now and you
can see there's a pretty big difference
in color I'm actually really impressed
by how different adults it's gotten a
lot yellow which is actually a good
thing for me since I'm heading towards
peach which has a lot more yellow terms
than my old purple so here's the purple
color here's the treated version my hair
feels pretty rough but it still feels
pretty strong so now I'm gonna do the
other side and then maybe draw the
second treatment and hopefully that will
fade even more and then yeah I'll be
ready to read I my hair I ended up doing
two rounds of the treatment for each
side of my hair before read eyeing it to
a peach color which you've probably seen
on some of my other videos I hope you
like this video if you did give it a
thumbs up and you can subscribe to my
channel as well leave me a comment
letting me know what else you want me to
talk about next you can also follow me
on Instagram and check out my blog for
more beauty signs see you next time